finney smith to inbound  back to doncic dodges pulls up  three-pointer  bang bang it's good doncic wins the game  at the buzzer  [Applause]  and he had the presence of mind to know  exactly how long  3.7 seconds was  [Applause]  it's the shot he works on time and time  again  rhythm step back three that's in his  resume  what a performance by luca and the  mavericks  mama there goes that man  we are witnessing the next great star in  the nba  in his first playoff series  i mean he airballed three threes tonight  i believe  and then to have the mental  strength to keep believing and use the  dribbles  to get his space and his spot and his  shot  brilliant let's hear from him and go to  cassidy